le problème de la cuisine des kebabs
après tous les gens peuvent manger ce
qu'ils veulent on est encore même en
pays de liberté un peu comme aux
États-Unis comme ailleurs le problème
c'est dans manger trop d'en manger de
temps en temps se faire plaisir pourquoi
pas le problème c'est que en plus ça
touche on sait que on peut parler de ici
de quand c'est bien fait un kebab bien
fait c'est comme une bonne pizza bien
faite il y a pas de problème dans le
sujet on voit bien qu'il y a des gens
qui achètent des produits tout fait des
produits complètement industrialisés et
le produit ultra transformé c'est ça le
problème et c'est le problème pour nos
enfants puisque aujourd'hui on sait que
à peu près 40 46% c'est les chiffres qui
donnent de produits ultra transformés
sont consommés par les enfants et parler
tout à l'heure de retraite s'il y a un
problème c'est pour nous payer une
retraite si les mots ils bouffent trop
de produits industriels être produit
ultra transformés ils vont pas aller
loin pour nous payer la retraite alors
c'est quoi la balle bouffe pour vous la
malbouffe en fait c'est de la nourriture
qui n'est pas saine je dirais d'un point
de vue physiologique quand on la mange
la malbouffe sont tous les produits trop
sucré trop gras trop salé d'ailleurs il
y a les pubs les mots ils voient à
travers toutes les pubs à chaque fois
Manger Bouger sucré salé attention aux
légumes par jour voilà et donc les cinq
fruits et légumes par jour et donc la
malbouffe elle vient de là c'est-à-dire
la malbouffe et moi je je sais pas si
vous avez vu ce film qui était sorti en
2013 qui s'appelait Fooding Corporated
ça s'appelle les alimenter tous les
spectateurs ils peuvent le voir non mais
c'est un film c'est hyper intéressant
parce que il y a un sujet sur la
malbouffe c'est que ça cause c'est pas
simplement de mal manger c'est que ça a
un problème de santé publique et donc de
coût pour tout le monde et quand on voit
aux États-Unis que le coût de la
malbouffe donc c'est aussi produit trop
transformé donc pas assez sain coûte 200
milliards de dollars en France c'est
peut-être 20 à 30 milliards d'euros on
voit bien que ça pose problème et par
exemple la malbouffe le dernier sujet
qui a fait quand même polémique et dont
il y avait un très bon papier d'ailleurs
dans le challenge sur les parents qu'on
portait plante peinte contre Nestlé à
propos des pizzas bio alors vous avez
des pizzas Bitoni et là vous mangez ça
vous pensez que vos mômes vont manger
correctement et là vous en avez et j'en
avais une soixantaine dont certains sont
sous dialyse et ça c'est à vie c'est le
même sujet dans le sujet du film
américain les alimentaires où on voit un
môme
qui mange un hamburger pas de problème
jusque là sauf qu'il a c'est toujours
cette bactérie ecoli et qui se retrouve
à l'hôpital et qui meurt et ben on
essaie dans ce cas-là aurait pu agir
c'est une fois de plus c'est
l'industriels qui veulent gagner du
pognon j'ai rien contre les gens qui
veulent gagner le pognon mais on doit
gagner correctement
dans le cas de Nestlé
déjà des problèmes et des gens qui
avaient des lanceurs d'alerte qui avait
dit qu'il y avait des problèmes de
d'hygiène déjà bien sûr plusieurs mois à
l'avance alors on va on va voir hier ce
qui s'est passé on vient de voir des
images des cuisines des kebabs mais
attention lorsque vous consommez ce
genre de repas faut faire également
attention à la qualité de la viande
malheureusement celle-ci est souvent
surgelée regardez ça
alors que pense notre expert des broches
surgelées surgelés ça m'inspire rien du
tout dans ce carton sous cette épée
plastique se cache une broche prête à
l'emploi là ce que vous voyez c'est le
gras de veau à mon avis en vaut ils ont
dû mettre surtout que le gras alors
comment savoir si un établissement
utilise ce type de produit surgelés
l'embout métallique on voit ici la sur
broche voilà là on voit très bien ça
c'est l'indice qui pas trompé alors ça
c'est indice il peut pas tromper et si
vous vous demandez ce que contient cette
viande surgelée et bien regardez
Sylvie travaille pour une société qui a
lancé une application qui classe les
produits en fonction de leur niveau de
transformation
et sur notre broche le nombre
d'ingrédients est déjà effarant bah 18
ingrédients oui ça fait beaucoup de
choses on est sur des produits qui sont
ultra transformés vu tout ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur c'est que la qualité de la
viande n'est pas forcément très bonne
dans le détail Sylvie découvre plusieurs
additifs qui remplacent une marinade
pour donner de la tenue mais aussi du
goût comme le glutamate monosodique un
petit cocktail réputé dangereux pour la
santé vous l'aurez compris ce produit
ultra transformé et potentiellement
nocif à haute dose
alors on va revenir après je vous
parlais du concentré de tomate mais il
faut savoir la malbouffe nous entoure en
permanence et celle-ci est encore plus
dangereuse de ce qu'on pourrait penser
un décès sur cinq dans le monde est
associé à une mauvaise alimentation soit
11 millions de morts par an en compte 11
millions de morts c'est ça Xavier ouais
tout à fait sont des chiffres qui sont
assez effarants ce qu'il faut savoir ça
tue quasiment plus que le tabac donc
c'est bien sûr c'est c'est colossal mais
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que on peut et
ça ce sont des politiques publiques on
peut lutter contre ce phénomène si les
politiques voulaient s'en emparer c'est
pour ça que tu as présenté mon livre à
la fin de mon lit je fais des
propositions bien sûr claire et précise
depuis des années pour entre autres
savoir ce qu'on mange donc entre autres
quand on va au restaurant ou à la
cantine moi j'avais proposé des logos
quand ça d'un produit ultra transformé
bah ça doit être indiqué aujourd'hui les
lobbies on peut parler de lobby que ce
soit de la restauration de l'industrie
agréable etc tout le monde lutte pour
empêcher la transparence or que ce soit
dans la République ou que ce soit dans
nos assiettes la transparence c'est la
base pour que ça fonctionne donc déjà
c'est d'informer les gens sur ce qu'ils
vont manger ensuite pour lutter contre
la malbouffe il faut faire de la
pédagogie moi je proposais
qu'effectivement dans l'éducation que ce
soit dans le privé ou l'éducation
nationale qui est des cours sur
l'alimentation donc on est des cours que
les enfants comprennent le sens
l'intérêt de bien manger que ce soit
d'ailleurs j'avais des copains qui
étaient chefs de cantine je peux faire
une salutation par exemple Christophe de
manger qui était un chef très très
engagé
on les appelle les pédagogues du goût
c'est-à-dire qu'à la cantine il montre
aux enfants qu'est-ce qu'ils vont manger
vous pouvez venir à 10h du matin par
exemple à la récré et on vous montre on
vous fait la démo tchat tu vas manger ça
et tout et les mots ça les intéresse et
quand vous faites ça et ben vous voyez
que les enfants dans les cantines
mangent autrement et demain chez eux ils
mangeront autrement et le problème de
l'alimentation sur transformée on
parlait de produits de sucre de cacher
les sucres par exemple ce sont les
produits du kraking c'est-à-dire des
produits issus du maïs ils utilisent
beaucoup ça aux États-Unis c'est très
très dangereux pour la santé parce que
en fait qu'est-ce que vous faites sans
le savoir vous grossissez sans le savoir
vous avez des maladies cardiovasculaires
de l'obésité etc alors
Delphine qui est spécialiste Xavier il y
a quand même un problème je sais que
vous avez militaire pour une meilleure
alimentation dans les cantines mais si
on ne le fait pas c'est parce que ça
coûte cher tous ces aliments comment on
fait venir des tomates de producteur
dans une cantine où il y a 1000 enfants
qui vont manger à midi est-ce que c'est
pas irréaliste non alors déjà Gilles a
raison de soulever le sujet
effectivement on peut paraître a priori
ça peut paraître coûter cher toi or et
je parlais de Christophe de manger tout
de suite ou d'autres chefs il démontrer
qu'on pouvait faire à manger pour deux 2
euros 2 euros 50 correctement aux
enfants en suivant naturellement la
saison tu vois j'ai ramené des produits
de saison c'est quoi ça
[Rires]
ça ça vaut en ce moment entre en
fonction des régions où tu es entre 1
euro et 2 euros la patate
les patates ça vaut grosso modo même pas
1 € le kilo un oignon
avec ça tu peux faire à peu près avec ça
on va se faire une sauce on va se faire
une soupe
de potimarron ce qu'il faut expliquer
c'est que quand tu fais une soupe
d'accord ça va te prendre donc tu vas
l'éplucher ça va te prendre allez une
demi-heure trois quarts même deux ans
une demi-heure tu cuis ton truc tu peux
écouter tu peux même regarder touche pas
à ton poste pendant que ça cuit etc
quand tu vas l'avoir mixer tu en as pour
la semaine c'est-à-dire que les gens les
gens qui ont pas les moyens ils se
disent j'achète des produits ultra
transformés parce que dedans il y a du
gras du sucre et tout et je crois bien
nourrir or quand ils font ça parce que
parce que souvent c'est des précaires il
faut savoir quand même que la mauvaise
alimentation touche principalement des
classes sociaux économiques
c'est un endroit où l'État peut mettre
des moyens où on peut faire à manger
donc pour grosso modo
d'accord après tu achètes du bon pain
qui peut se garder t'es pas obligé
d'acheter une baguette industrielle on
peut trouver du pain moi j'achète une
miche de pain au marché le samedi j'en
ai pour toute la semaine donc bien sûr
ça bouge pas le pain ce qu'on appelle le
vrai pain paysan tu le mets dans une
dans un torchon tu es dans un sac qui
bouge pas
c'est nickel donc il y a des des petites
choses comme ça du quotidien et dans les
cantines on y pense on peut le faire
donc il s'agit à l'état à qui ça coûte
et je finis vas-y l'État à qui ça coûte
fini à la côte 20 ou 30 milliards par an
si tu rajoutes juste un milliard dans
les cantines sur le long terme tu
gagneras peut-être des dizaines de
milliards de maladie Delphine il y a une
citation qui dit on creuse ça tombe avec
ses dents ah ouais parce que
effectivement
c'est très imagé c'est très vrai
puisqu'on mange généralement deux à
trois repas par jour donc si on mange de
la merde elle va concrètement on va se
trouver une maladie
et si on mange bien ça s'appelle des
aliments et en fait le les aliments sont
les meilleurs médicaments
et ça en fait c'est tout l'inverse des
produits transformés c'est pour ça que
dans les dans les dans les pubs il
faudrait mettre ne pas manger trop gras
trop sucré trop salé et trop transformé
en fait c'est vraiment ça
d'accord avec vous si l'état mettait
comment dire de l'argent
dans l'éducation et dans la sécurité
sociale enfin que tous que tout le monde
se met en lien pour que nos jeunes aient
la meilleure nourriture et en plus ça
pourrait sponsoriser enfin tous les
comment dire les les paysans aux
alentours pour les pour le circuit court
et ça c'est très intelligent les
médicaments et tu constates avec tes
dents avec ses dents donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut bien réfléchir chaque heure
on a creusé des tombes
aussi ça que les gens qui mangent des
kebabs ils ont bien sûr le temps de se
mijoter
qui sont plus simples les kebabs par
exemple
quand tu es dehors c'est plus compliqué
c'est-à-dire que oui je sais pas si tu
te souviens avant les ouvriers ils
avaient leur boîte sur la boîte à manger
plus on met si tu manges dehors tu
manges dehors la plupart du temps en
moyenne les gens qui travaillent trois
quatre fois à l'extérieur il te reste
encore beaucoup de repas parce que tu as
mangé trois quatre fois dehors un peu
mal que tu dois manger mal à la maison
après le temps que tu passes le temps
que tu passes à faire tes courses moi je
conseille de faire les marchés ouverts
le samedi ou le dimanche
encore une fois le temps que tu vas
consacrer c'est du temps que tu vas
économiser aussi sur la sur ta santé
soit toujours de la malbouffe le temps
que tu vas économiser le temps que tu
vas faire à manger
il faut bien choisir ses produits tu
vois moi
tu me fais plaisir aussi tu retrouves
l'art de la table en France on parle
beaucoup du pays de l'art de la table
alors que on a les le pays où il y a
McDo est le premier implantation après
les États-Unis donc on voit bien que on
doit retrouver ça on doit convaincer ça
en France parce que c'est notre culture
alors tout à l'heure on parlait Delphine
c'est ça j'aime bien Delphine moi bah
écoute c'est pas le seul
Guillaume et sur le dossier depuis le 26
ans pas ne crois pas que tu vas arriver
avec tes potiron et tes conneries et que
tu vas la caisse non mais je te le dis
hein parce que tu as ramené un cageot
que tu vas repartir
[Rires]
pourquoi la saison on est dans la saison
aujourd'hui des pommes et des kiwis ça
c'est les pommes et des kiwis qui
viennent de Lot-et-Garonne
est dans le Gers mais c'est pas grave
attention
je vais croquer dans Daniel slogan un
peu le deck équipe de docteur avant de
manger tu manges une pomme docteur
ta digestion par exemple et tu manges
des pommes et des kiwis donc les pommes
et les kiwis en ce moment le kiwi au
lieu de l'acheter de la Nouvelle-Zélande
tu achètes des kiwis Nouvelle-Zélande il
faut pas en acheter les autres endroits
les kiwis en France ça pousse d'Espagne
en Italie mais ça pousse et tu les as à
partir de novembre il faut avoir une
carte et sans plus cher non ils sont
beaucoup moins cher
puisque c'est la saison des kiwis en
France et là les kiwis moi j'achète ça
pour mes restaurants ça vaut 1 € 1 €.
non
on est sur dehors calibre
donc ça veut dire que si tu prends du
plus gros ça 20 centimes 30 centimes le
20 centimes le kiwi alors que quand tu
achètes au supermarché ils viennent de
nouvelles Zélande tu le paye souvent 50
70 centimes et même plus peut-être moi
je parle de voilà donc en fait si tu
suis les saisons
il faut juste passer du temps il faut
passer du temps donc ça c'est une
question de parler on va parler
justement on va parler de tomates
la plupart des pizzas sont composées de
concentrer de tomates mais en vérité
c'est pas vraiment ce qu'il y a dedans
et d'où ça vient ça regardez c'est
intéressant le concentré de tomate tu
vois j'aime bien moi je croyais que
c'était juste une tomate qui était hyper
concentré
se concentrer de tomates et fabriqué en
Chine quand il arrive en Europe il a
toujours la nationalité chinoise mais
aucune information sur l'origine des
tomates
l'Union européenne ne l'impose pas pire
il suffit d'y ajouter des ingrédients
comme de l'eau pour que le produit
prenne la nationalité du pays sur lequel
il est transformé
et voilà comment du concentré chinois
devient européen pour les autorités il
s'agit bien de la plus grande fraude
alimentaire mise au jour
c'est fou ça alors
le sujet le sujet c'est que c'est pas
que ça vient seulement de Chine c'est le
problème de savoir comment se cultivé en
Chine comment ces produits comment
souvent il y avait des sujets d'ailleurs
sur d'autres chaînes ont montré les des
camions qui restaient en plein cagnard
etc ou c'était les ouiours là dans le
sud
voici la prison de bahing golem tout
autour de l'établissement pénitentiaire
apparaissent des champs ou travaillerait
les détenus majoritairement des Ouigours
en Chine il est interdit à une prison de
vendre sa production mais nous avons
découvert une parade pour contourner la
loi selon cet article de presse chinois
la prison de bahingolen aurait créé une
société d'agriculture pour vendre ses
produits cette entreprise
commercialiserait ses conserves à base
de tomates récoltées par les prisonniers
et en Italie c'est pas mieux puisque les
tomates sont récoltées dans des
conditions particulièrement précaires
avec des individus en situation
irrégulière qui n'ont pas leur mot à
dire regarder
les personnes qui ramassent les précieux
fruits sont pour la plupart exploités
des immigrés sans papier venus d'Afrique
ces immigrés sont rémunérés presque deux
fois moins qu'un salarié payé dans les
règles c'est ici qu'habite des dizaines
de travailleurs les conditions de vie
sont extrêmement précaires sans eau
potable ni sanitaire évidemment aucune
rébellion pour ces personnes en
situation irrégulière car il est
extrêmement difficile de trouver du
travail un cercle vicieux qui permet aux
agriculteurs d'empocher le gros lot en
réduisant leur coûts puisque se
concentrer sera vendu plus de 20% moins
cher que la moyenne sur la sauce tomate
pour ce qu'on a vu sur ce produit qu'on
dit qu'il est européen en fait il vient
de Chine cette petite magouille ça c'est
on le savait depuis longtemps ça ou pas
oui ça on sait depuis longtemps mais
dans le sujet il montre aussi que ce
soit en Italie ou sûrement en Chine il y
a aussi de la production qui est où les
gens sont payés correctement les choses
sont faites faut faire quand même faire
la balance c'est le cas de le dire mais
ce qui est important de de dire c'est
qu'effectivement ces produits alors
qu'on a des produits de saison et de la
tomate en France ou en Europe etc c'est
que des produits ont traversé le monde
entier sont ultra transformés et
effectivement on y perd un peu son latin
moi dans mon livre il y a tout un
chapitre où je raconte l'histoire du
lapin de Chine dans les cantines je
découvre il y a quelques années
c'est vrai que c'est oui avec C8 j'avais
fait un sujet ou dans la cantine de mon
fils en plein cœur du Lot-et-Garonne
qu'est-ce que je trouve du lapin il
mangeait du lapin de Chine quand même
dingue
il est venu comment en bateau en
île de la tentation
mais c'est pas les mêmes fous de lapin
donc du coup tu sais c'est un animal a
des animaux les plus mal élevés comme la
viande
il m'a traité ils sont mal élevé c'est
vrai donc ils sont très mal élevés donc
faut en fait comme c'est un élevage qui
est ça casse pas des briques quand ça
vient de Chine on peut imaginer que
c'est encore pire donc les mots manger
ça donc il savait pas c'est pour ça que
à ce moment là j'ai demandé à au
gouvernement à l'époque d'ailleurs
c'était dans le dans le sujet des
gallimes bien sûr
on a fait qui a pas débouché sur un truc
extraordinaire mais l'idée c'était de
dire c'est pas normal que les mots que
les parents ne savent pas parce que dès
le moment où ils ont appris que le lapin
venait de Chine donc c'était de la main
transformer une paupiettes et ensuite
parce que j'étais mettre mon on est dans
la hein parce que c'est lapin qui l'a
dit genre tu viens d'où je viens de
Chine
mais je repars demain là je suis là que
pour deux jours
une des propositions je fais c'est que
tous les parents puissent accéder à ce
qui est fait dans les cieux
bien manger indispensable bien manger
c'est bien vivre hein
regardez les étiquettes au moment où au
sein des étiquettes en fait parce qu'il
faudrait qu'il y ait des sous lignes en
fait parce que là on dit que un produit
chinois mélangé à de l'eau européenne
mais on nous dit pas qu'à la base ça
vient de Chine non c'est pas forcément
donc sur le lapin on était déjà parce
que quand même un effort puisque sur les
viandes aujourd'hui que ce soit dans la
restauration dans les cantines ou
partout on doit indiquer la provenance
de la viande donc aujourd'hui même
normalement dans les produits
transformés on doit indiquer d'où vient
le poulet d'où vient alors ça peut parce
que il est il est élevé en France qu'il
est bien parce que tu peux avoir du
poulet poulet qui est vite élevé
industriel des alors c'est vrai que sur
les œufs les œufs sont pas chers on a
sur la coquille 0 pour le bio un pour le
plein air et 3 pour les œufs donc les
gens voient bien que dès les gens sont
informés dès qu'ils sont informés
donc informés
c'est mauvais pour le l'oseille c'est
mauvais pour les c'est vraiment mauvais
pour l'oseille des grands des grandes
boîtes vaut mieux ne pas informer sur le
bide des gens mais par contre un citoyen
informé on vaut peut-être une dizaine ah
c'est ça d'utiliser à l'étranger et
interdit en France quoi ils utilisent
des pesticides à l'étranger ils
utilisent des pesticides à l'étranger
qui sont pourtant interdits en France
d'accord pour produire plus par exemple
et peste c'est pas vrai ou c'est pas
vrai toi c'est vrai
dans une dizaine de jours enfin la fin
du mois le Salon de l'Agriculture donc
c'est vraiment c'est un vrai sujet
tu devrais inviter mon mon pote Bernard
Michel qui a un chien bien sûr il est
dans mon bouquin tu vas faire il y a un
chapitre tu lis tu vas t'éclater le mec
il est je sais Bernard
Michel il sera pendant 10 jours au salon
de l'agriculture moi c'est un personnage
j'ai invité Bernard et Bernard Bernard
oui qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce que je
voulais dire le par rapport au concentré
de tomates il y a un côté sordide c'est
que comme ils ont détruit ça dans le
monde entier on prend l'exemple d'un
pays d'Afrique le Ghana qui fabriquait
ma sœur voilà il y avait des Pelé qui
n'est absolument c'est j'adore ben oui
il fabriquait massivement du concentré
de tomate maintenant il y a plus rien
les chinois ils ont ruinés et et les
gens du Ghana viennent illégalement
comme pour ramasser ce qu'on voyait tout
à l'heure les champs de tomates en
Italie donc au niveau de l'immigration
clandestine ça joue aussi c'est pour ça
qu'il faut rétablir les équilibres et
que les chinois sont en train de tuer
l'économie mondiale voilà et oui le
Chinois et les Russes mais là c'est les
Chinois Bernard
juste question pratique tout à l'heure
Géraldine disait si on n'a pas le temps
on emmène de chez soi un morceau de pain
et du fromage et ça que ce soit le pain
au fromage en fait c'est acidifie le
corps donc j'invite tout le monde à
aller regarder sur internet qu'est-ce
que le corps acide
c'est un pipi acide c'est un pipi acide
c'est un pipi qui attaque il faut
prendre les animaux parce que plus vous
prenez des choses acides plus ça fait
des maladies donc regardez sur internet
avec du chèvre et une pomme
c'est des remontées gastriques
calme-toi bébé t'inquiète pas
concentre-toi pense au 8 mars
merci Xavier si on se mettait enfin à
table le livre de Xavier de Namur qui
est de France de Paris en fait la région
parisienne